currently wildlife has no value no
economic value to ranchers and as such
the ranchers don't want them around if
it doesn't pay it doesn't stick
many Americans trace the modern
conservation movement back to Theodore
Roosevelt known for his love of the
outdoors and for creating the US Forest
Service in the National Park System
but what if government isn't the only or
the best entity to protect America's
natural wonders we also have a history
in this country of private initiative
right if you go back further to the
Roosevelt spoon and Crockett Club for
example it was a combination of artists
and wealthy people and writers and they
came together and they said hey we care
about conservation and we can do this on
our own and we can invite people from
all over the country to join us the
American prairie reserve is a group that
wants to establish the largest Nature
Reserve in the lower 48 states and it
aims to do so with private funding
people often wonder about how big the
current reserve is now and what its
goals are well the end 3/9 million acres
is 5,000 square miles roughly the size
of the state of Connecticut the group
still has a ways to go before reaching
its goal of more than 3 million acres
stretching across northern Montana but
it's already purchased or leased more
than three hundred thousand acres of
land with individual properties larger
than the entire city of Los Angeles the
group hopes to stitch together these
lands with existing public land to
eventually create a space where plants
and animals can thrive and be enjoyed by
visitors our model is a deliberate blend
of private philanthropy working in
cooperation with the federal government
I think everybody who lives in the
American West particularly in Montana is
thankful that there are these large
swaths of federal public lands that
provide us recreation and all sorts of
amenity benefits the problem we see is
these resources are stressed the federal
government the National Park Service has
a maintenance backlog in the billions of
dollars for example there are just
fundamental limits to what the
government can do in an era of serious
fiscal constraints we think rather than
sitting around and waiting and lobbying
the government to put together these big
ecologically meaningful
landscapes private actors like ourself
can really mobilize and achieve
significant conservation goals using a
slightly different model
there was this big era of park building
in the United States and it ended in the
50s really with Grand Teton National
Park and in my opinion part of the
reason that ended it was it was so
cumbersome and there was conflict one
consistent area of conflict that
national parks face is one with ranchers
and hunters who rely on the land for
food and money we've seen it play out
with the Bundy ranch confrontation in
Nevada and more recently with the
occupation of a ranger station in Oregon
most national parks in the US and Beyond
have had these battles that you've
probably heard about in the news when
wolf or bison cross over the boundary of
the public park into the private
property there's kind of guns aiming in
there's a fundamental problem at Cal
consume grass as well as other wildlife
so you have a competition for resources
currently wildlife has no economic value
to ranchers and as such the ranchers
don't want them around but the American
prairie reserve is testing out a way to
work with ranchers to conserve wildlife
so that everybody wins wild sky is a
brand in a company privately owned
called Montana Prairie Holdings that is
a for-profit out there selling beef
selling about 50,000 pounds a month all
over the United States and the
fundamental goal of starting a
for-profit company is its sustainable
over the longer term we generated 3.3
million last year in sales American
prairie reserve uses the profits from
wild sky beef to pay ranchers to help
them create the soft borders that allow
wildlife to thrive ranchers can plant
native grasses allow prairie dogs to
establish colonies and create gaps in
their fences to allow herd animals like
deer and elk to pass through the more
goal posts they pass and the more
wildlife they observe on their property
the bigger the payout is
the fundamental purpose is to change the
social dynamic the sociology of the area
the way people think about wildlife
something different than the way they've
thought about it in the past we've seen
prairie dog towns increasing we've seen
for the first time on one ranch a black
bear he's also some mountain lion on his
property never seen that so we're making
some good steps if American prairie
reserve succeeds it will be one and a
half times the size of Yellowstone
National Park and they believe that a
success that big will provide a lesson
for other western states the approach
that we're employing is unique only in
the sense that we're actually doing it
the conservationists with a market
orientation I've been thinking and
writing about this kind of thing for
decades and the Dean much of this
intellectual work was done here in
Bozeman but we're actually applying this
model on the ground as we're successful
and we gain more attention over time
you'll see other groups trying to put
this together on a much larger scale I
think that's really the important thing
is the scale at which were working